style madame est nominé sur la parole
est à monsieur jean luc warsmann
oui merci monsieur le président ma
question porte sur l'exil forcé à
l'étranger de nombreuses personnes
handicapées bellamy le ministre souhaite
attirer votre attention sur les
difficultés de milliers de familles de
notre pays dont un membre est handicapé
permettez moi un instant de citer
quelques chiffres concernant mon seul
département dans les ardennes 2677
personnes en situation de handicap ont
fait l'objet d'une décision favorable
pour intégrer un établissement sur ses
2600 sont 17 à cet instant nous
échangeons 385 personnes qui se sont vu
reconnaître le droit et hébergées en
établissement
son cheptel faute de place et reste à
leur domicile
souvent dans des conditions difficiles
pour elles mêmes ou leur famille
un dernier chiffre cent cinquante deux
personnes handicapées sont hébergés à
l'étranger faute de place dans notre
pays
revenons au niveau national en 2015
l'assurance maladie a versé 170 millions
d'euros et les conseils départementaux
plus de 200 millions d'euros à des
établissements l'étranger faute de place
pour accueillir les personnes
handicapées vous comprendront donc pas
la milice que j'ai deux questions à vous
poser la première question peut-on
lancer une augmentation des capacités
d'accueil dans notre pays pour répondre
aux besoins et ma deuxième question
peut-on à mais progressivement une
réduction des sommes versées aux
établissements étrangers pour les verser
à nos propres établissements médico
sociaux pour ouvrir de nouvelles places
aux personnes aux personnes permettent
aux personnes handicapées d'avoir des
solutions d'hébergement à proximité et
enfin la ministre
cela permettrait aussi de créer de
l'emploi dans nos établissements médico
sociaux
je vous remercie merci la parole de
komlan ségolène neuville secrétaire
d'état chargé des personnes handicapées
et de la lutte contre l'exclusion
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
je pense que sur le sujet du handicap
effectivement nous pouvons tomber
d'accord sur un certain nombre de
constats le premier d'entre eux étant
effectivement qu'un certain nombre
d'enfants et d'adultes en situation de
handicap n'ont pas de solutions adaptées
à leurs besoins à l'heure actuelle c'est
la raison pour laquelle ce gouvernement
s'emploie à résoudre ses difficultés
depuis maintenant cinq ans alors
évidemment il ya un premier aliment
qui est celui de créer des places et
donc depuis 2012 il ya maintenant dix
neuf mille places supplémentaires entre
les établissements et les services pour
enfants et adultes confondus
mais créer des nouvelles places ça ne
suffit pas pour une raison simple c'est
que quand on crée des places eh bien on
ne s'adapte pas forcément ou handicap de
chaque personne ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que toutes les personnes
handicapées ne vont pas dans le même
type d'établissement vun accueillez pas
au même endroit un enfant autiste et un
adulte avec une paralysie cérébrale
donc il ya toute la question de
l'adaptation à chaque personne et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons d'une
part changer la loi en permettant que
les personnes puissent se retourner vers
les mdph quand elles n'ont pas de
solution pour dire qu'est ce que vous
faites pour trouver une solution et
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle nous
changeons les pratiques des nombreuses
administrations mdph agences régionales
de santé éducation nationale tous les
services de l'état mais aussi des
associations gestionnaires
d'établissements et concernant la
belgique vous avez raison c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle nous avons lancé un
plan de pour stopper les départs non
souhaitée en belgique qui est maintenant
qui se met en oeuvre depuis
progressivement un an avec un mécanisme
simple qui consiste à faire des
extensions dans d'importantes
d'établissements et de services dans les
endroits où il ya ces besoins la est
dirigée vers les personnes qui en ont
besoin à ce moment là et donc il s'agit
principalement de personnes qui ont des
troubles de comportement et qui ne
trouvent pas de place dans l'est dans
les établissements près de chez eux
donc tout est fait justement pour
résoudre ces situations et sachez que
aussi bien les départements doivent se
mobiliser sur cette question que le
gouvernement